- Nina wants me to make her a smoothie!
(upbeat music)
All right believe nation, happy weekend,
Nina wants me to make her a smoothie.
And so I'm going to get my best shot.
She's going to hopefully guide me,
and I'm looking forward to hearing
what you guys have to think,
and your favorite smoothie recipes.
Let's do it!
Nina!
- Huh?
- What am I doing?
- [Nina] Just wash the kale.
- Wash the kale, I can do that.
- [Nina] But first wash the sink first,
otherwise the sink is gross.
- Listen, I'm going to do it my way.
- [Nina] No, kale, wash the sink.
- It's my smoothie for you to drink.
- [Nina] No, for me to drink,
of course it has to be clean.
If it's not clean I'm
going to get stomach ache
and I'll have to bother you all day.
- Ooh, doesn't sound good.
I'm going to plug in the camera
'cause it's battery's going to die.
Okay, step one, I need kale, let's go.
Kale, where's the kale?
Where's the kale?
- [Nina] In the fridge!
- I'm in the fridge, do we need carrots?
- No.
- No carrots?
- [Nina] Just kale and cucumber.
- Pizza, how 'about some pizza?
- [Nina] You can have the pizza.
- Yummy smoothie?
Kale, kale.
Ah, I found the kale!
I found some kale!
Okay how much kale Nina?
- [Nina] All!
- What, all of it?
- Yes.
- All of the kale, there's a
red pepper in with the kale.
- [Nina] You eat the red pepper,
but don't put it in the smoothie.
- Kale and?
- [Nina] Cucumbers!
- Cucumbers, how much?
- [Nina] One!
- Okay, and?
- [Nina] Banana and the fruit, that's it.
- Banana?
Banana, the brown banana?
- [Nina] Yes!
- [Evan] These are good?
- [Nina] Yes.
- These look nasty, look at this.
Look at this, holy cow.
How many, one banana?
- [Nina] Yes.
- Kind of afraid to touch
these bananas to be honest.
Have you ever seen a
banana this black before?
- [Nina] Okay, it's okay, just do it.
- This is,
holy cow, is this what
you put in my smoothies?
Anything else, other fruits?
- [Nina] Frozen fruit.
- Frozen fruits.
Do these qualify as fruits, what is this?
Dates?
- [Nina] And the frozen
fruits in the freezer.
- Frozen fruits are in the freezer,
that's some quality
guidelines right there.
- [Nina] Baby it's making fun of you.
- This thing?
- Yeah!
- This thing, how much of this?
- [Nina] One handful, that's it.
- One handful, I'm going to put
my hand in this frozen fruit.
It's like one giant block
cube of frozen fruit.
I don't know how to
separate that, we'll see.
Okay, guys, to make this epic
smoothie, you need, ready?
This is exact proportions,
you need this much kale,
one rotten banana, you
need a whole cucumber,
and a handful of frozen fruit.
Okay, what do we need to wash?
The cucumber, do we need to wash Nina?
- [Nina] Yes.
- Cucumber, you guys, you need to wash.
Banana, we don't need to
wash, we just need to get
a tetanus shot before, and
the kale we need to wash,
so let's do some washing.
(playful piano music)
Cut off the edge of the cucumber.
All right, we are ready to blend.
What?
- [Nina] You have to wash the kale.
- I washed the kale.
- No.
- I did.
- [Nina] No, how many kale did you put in?
- The whole thing.
- No baby, okay, I'll wash it.
- What do you mean?
It's right there, I washed it.
- I'll wash it baby.
- I washed the whole thing,
look at it.
- No, that's not how you wash it.
- I washed the kale, Nina's not happy
with how I washed the kale,
she's going to wash it.
What is it, that's garbage?
- Yes.
- [Evan] How come?
- [Nina] It's just the
yellow and the stems.
- Guys, pro tip, if it's yellow
and it has stems on kale,
you don't blend that stuff, okay?
Get your act together.
All right, now we're ready to blend!
So we use a Vitamix, get
out your Vitamix guys!
Are we just going to put
everything in it, and just blend?
Huh?
- Yes.
- No water or anything?
- [Nina] Yes, water.
- Water, like how much water?
- [Nina] Up to half.
- Up to half water?
Really?
Okay, we're going to
put some water in here,
we're not quite sure how
much, maybe up to half,
but first we put all of our
ingredients in the Vitamix.
Professional level here, okay?
Got my kale, starting with the kale.
Squash that in there.
This is epic, wow, this is a lot of kale.
We have our cucumber, the
professional way to do this
is to break it in half like that,
and squash it into the
Vitamix as much as you can.
'Kay?
Next, we have our rotten banana.
I feel like I need special
gloves to hold this thing,
but let's peel it.
Oh it's getting all mushy just
peeling it, this is nasty,
you know what, I'm going
to cut off the top.
Oh, guys, oh my God, this is so gross.
Okay guys, use your special gloves,
I don't need gloves because
I'm Evan Carmichael.
But if you're handling a banana like this,
this is just not, guys, look at this,
this is what we keep in the fridge.
This is nastiest thing--
- It's not nasty!
- This is, this is just,
I don't want to touch
this, I am Evan Carmichael
but even touching this, I
feel like it's going to,
look, it can't even stay up by itself,
it's so soggy this thing.
This is just wrong, okay, guys, banana,
don't touch the actual banana,
find a way to get it in there
without touching anything 'cause,
you might get an infection.
Okay, there, it sticks up but that's okay.
- [Nina] How 'about the tip, the tip?
- What do you want, the tip off?
- [Nina] Cut it off.
- Okay guys, when you
see the tip like that,
you may think, wow, that's
a nasty looking tip, so,
(giggling)
let's keep this entire nasty banana,
but that, that's gross, oh
my God let's cut that off!
Okay?
Oh, wow, it's so much better now!
This is nasty, okay, guys, if
it's hanging out like this,
cut it in half, don't
touch it, you might die.
Oh man, okay, this is--
- You spat all over yourself.
- I spat on myself, it's
better than touching that,
I'm dying touching that thing.
Okay, so far we have this, next,
we take this giant block of frozen fruit
and take a handful of it somehow.
'Cause it's all smushed
together in one giant block
and I need to take a
handful of this somehow,
so let's see what happens.
This is what you learn on
this quality YouTube channel.
First challenge is undoing the knot, okay?
When there's a big giant
knot in a plastic bag
my tendency would be to
just rip a hole in the bag.
I'd have to deal with a
very angry Chinese woman
yelling at me, so I need to
find a way to undo this knot,
holy cow, it's frozen!
You know, they make special knots in China
that are extra tough, that you
apply to frozen fruit bags,
to prevent the animals from getting in.
Okay, there we go.
Now the wife's instructions
was, take a handful,
so let's try that.
Oh, this is working really
well, my hands are frozen.
How am I supposed to
take a handful of this?
- Oh my God, let me do,
no, no, no, don't you--
- Holy cow, that's frozen solid!
- [Nina] Let me help you!
- No no, you got to explain to me,
I can't need to, oh my God.
- Just shake--
- Just smash it?
- [Nina] Yeah.
- You're going to ruin the countertop.
- [Nina] You won't ruin this thing.
- This is a surprise video, okay?
At the end you better be really surprised
about this amazing thing
that I made for you.
That's hurts, okay, I need something.
- [Nina] No, just do that.
- I'm not going to smash
it on the countertop.
- [Nina] It won't break,
I've done that before.
- Hold on.
Guys, it's really important
when you're making smoothies
to not forget your hammer, okay?
Really important kitchen ingredient
that helps you in lots
of situations, okay?
We have our bag of frozen, I
want to say vegetables, fruit.
(soft pounding)
- [Nina] Oh my God!
- Guys, pro tip, when hammering
the fruit out of the bag,
aim it so that the bag is
not going towards the floor.
Now we need a handful.
- [Nina] Wash it, it's on the floor.
- Guys if you drop food on
the floor, you wash it, okay?
Oh my God it's so cold.
This is a handful.
Okay, handful of fruit, we
have one grape, one grape,
and then one blueberry, one blueberry,
four pieces of pineapple,
and three honeydew.
A honeydew, what is this?
That's the perfect
quantity for this smoothie,
so remember that, okay, when
you're buying your ingredients,
one blueberry, three pieces of pineapple.
When you tie the bag back
up, make sure it's not
in the crazy Chinese
knot so you can undo it.
Last step, before we blend
we got to add some water
'cause that is not going to blend.
So we put some water in here.
- [Nina] That's it.
- So just like that, so the water goes to,
can't even see it, where's the water line?
See there, see that water line?
That means it's perfect, okay?
Look at this, look at how
gross that banana looks on top,
that looks like the least
appetizing thing I've ever seen.
Look at that banana, bananas
are supposed to be yellow,
did you know that?
All right, Vitamix, let's
get our Vitamix out.
There it is, all right, we plug that in.
It's going to get noisy.
But it's going to be tasty, the
perfect entrepreneur smoothie
about to come out.
(blender buzzes)
And we're done!
This is actually super helpful
'cause you can smush it down
when it's not behaving.
There we go, look at that, awesome.
All I smell is cucumber, this looks nasty.
Okay, holy cow.
Things are falling on me, what
are we going to put it in?
Let's get our Starbucks tumbler.
How much do you want Nina?
- [Nina] Doesn't matter.
- Okay, doesn't matter,
let's get something smaller.
I should give it to her in
this, it'll make her freak out.
But, we got to be nice to her.
We'll do this, we'll do the
AWeber mug, AWeber mug, okay.
Let's pour that in there.
Perfect, so this is it.
This is the moment of truth
that we've all been waiting for.
Okay, Nina.
Nina, honey, I have a surprise for you!
I have a surprise, oh there
she is, look at what I made.
- [Nina] Oh, hello!
- Huh, okay?
Why don't you look at, why
don't you smile at the camera?
- Smell like cucumber.
- Yeah I know, there
was just one cucumber.
Okay try it.
- You going to have some?
- No.
I know what's in there, it's gross.
- It's not gross.
- That banana is going to
give me nightmares, dude.
You try it first, see
if you can handle it.
- That's what I've been
using in your smoothies.
- Okay, don't make me think
about that, okay go, and?
Holy cow you're downing it.
Okay, that's not how you drink a smoothie,
you drink it like it's water.
You're supposed to taste
it, can you enjoy the flavor
that I put into this?
- Yeah it's yummy.
- Is it?
- No it's yummy!
- All I see is rotten banana
and all I smell is cucumber.
There's a lot of backwash in here.
- Yeah I spit.
- It's not bad actually.
It's all me.
You know what it is,
it's the one blueberry,
made all the difference.
Guys make sure to add one blueberry.
It's not bad actually.
- You can have more.
Well if they want it sweeter
they could add more fruit.
- This is my video, okay,
you want Nina cooking video
go check out her cooking channel.
This is Life With Evan, okay?
Or Evan cooks, sometimes,
- What if you want, if
you want it to be sweeter,
you can put more fruit in there.
Or add a date in there, we have a date.
- I asked if you wanted dates.
- You didn't ask me.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, frozen dates.
- No.
- I did!
- Do these qualify as
fruits, what is this, dates?
- No, we don't have frozen dates.
- We don't have frozen
dates, what is this?
What's this?
- That's Chinese dates, it's not for--
- Oh, so Chinese dates are not dates.
- No I didn't say it's not date,
and it's not meant for smoothie,
there's another date in--
- So we have dates in the freezer.
- Okay, thank you guys for watching,
I hope you guys enjoyed this video,
it's such a really funny video.
Continue to believe in
whatever your one word,
we will see you soon, bye!
(giggling)
- You did good.
I mean you should be saying
that to me, I did good.
- You did well, baby, you did well.
- Chinese dates aren't dates.